Kevin Costner actor Academy
award-winning director producer musician
and here to talk about season two of
Yellowstone cables most-watched news
series debuts on paramount Network
that'll be coming up the 19th of this
month at 10:00 Eastern and Pacific good
to see again how's life everything's
good pretty pretty good when's the last
time you got excited about a sporting
event I was I was really excited to see
how this was gonna play out with with
the Raptors I mean I when I see
slow-motion footage and it's all been
there today narrated you know throughout
the years I've actually watched those
games so when I watch that stuff I've I
make a point to see these games that are
kind of pivotal and since I was probably
I mean I think the first time I said I
need to go see this game was when AJ was
in the preseason gonna play against the
Jets against Namath and I really wanted
to see that matchup and it was you know
you'd only see one game a week and that
was a preseason game so everything that
from the Super Bowls everything from the
the Final Fours everything from the I
make it a point to to really really try
to see that wherever I'm at but also you
know we look at Hollywood tries to
capture what happens in real life
with sporting events yeah like you know
miracle and ice you couldn't have
written it you know or it doesn't play
out that way but you know Spike Lee said
you know the the truth is always better
than you know the make-believe yeah I
mean it's the same it's the same thing
and like when I remember when I made
untouchables and I'm doing this one
scene I remember DePalma comes and goes
what are you doing
what is it you're doing and I said what
do you what do you mean what I did
you're always reloading and I said I
said yeah I said you know what there's
more drama in reloading I said there's a
lot of strategy that goes when a guy
runs out of bullets I said when the gun
never stops I've never believed it I
said so you know it's a spikes point the
reality of you only got six you figure
out how to use them or if you don't you
figure out how to get loaded and you do
your dialogue as you're loading so it
was kind of I kind of believe that the
truth is wait it's just as entertaining
us to lie but you had to
reload in the train station you had no I
counted him out that drove him crazy to
me because he's doing it in slow motion
I'm remembering going I said okay so
this guy's here so I got five because
I've taken the plug out he in shock and
it's normally three but if you take the
plug out which is illegal
you got five so the policy when it's
like so but I made it work so he didn't
he did a thing in slow motion I said I'm
doing it in real life and I said I go
people appreciate a survival instinct
you know you know when you know guys you
know a lot of people think I make movies
and there's great women characters and
they're so the ideas are well you make
movies that women like and I said it's
not true what I do is I make movies for
men I make sure that I'm kind of doing
what I think would I do something I hope
that some man watching that goes I get
that I get that he's I get that Billy
chapels sobbing in that hotel by himself
and nobody there to see his perfect game
when his parents saw every Little League
game everything and so you don't have
your girl you don't have your woman Bull
Durham is a love story but guys see it
as a baseball exactly so for me when I
insist on us having great women in the
movies great parts for that but I don't
do i I always feel like I got it past
the guy test I was also wondering about
this knowing that you were gonna be on
that imagine if acting was one take
because sports is live right like
Broadway's as close as we have to an
athletic performance
right how would performances be
different they'd be pretty different
because millat of glitches you'd really
need an editor because I'll tell you the
difference is is that when you do
theater you know you rehearse for two or
three months the state of movies has
gotten to where you show up and you're
hitting your marks I mean people people
don't rehearse anymore they block and
and I don't want to exclude some
directors because some directors still
believe in that process that you farm
the material and the movie will be
subtly a lot better but but it's like a
long lost art giving actors a rehearsal
I I'm two movies that I've directed the
three movies I've directed
we had two weeks of rehearsal and when I
was first introduced to the movie in The
Big Chill Lawrence Kasdan had 30 days at
a month where the cast was just together
and you know those are the foundations
that I like I mean a lot of people like
the red carpet I happen to like the
process I mean I'm not immune to you
know wanting to go and all my friends to
the red carpet but I I always it'd be I
guess like drawing a play that works a
play that you thought about and you get
into a critical moment you go let's do
that play and it works and there's
that's the satisfaction I get you know
from acting that's nothing what kind of
thing I normally explain to anybody but
I I still get a thrill out of
discovering something in a rehearsal
everybody goes well what about the movie
I just feel like I earned my dough when
I find something but if you it has the
first take made it into a movie oh yeah
I mean sometimes the lights going and
somebody looks at you and they go you
know I look at somebody I go this really
important scene and we're doing it right
now this is hot and you go go and you do
it so yeah first take and one stand out
no not really that I can that I can
think of that's probably the 35 years of
doing it nothing nothing stands out
anymore it's a blur it's like you know
you know but I when you say let's have a
catch
I'll tell you one thing that happened
yeah you know in JFK I am a real slow
study I'm slower than most actors it
takes me and I don't think I have some
kind of learning disorder I can't it
takes me a long time I have to have a
script for 20 days and just live with it
and live with a lot of people think my
acting is natural I hope it comes off
natural but it's not for me I I struggle
with getting the memory getting to be
able to perform and start to move on JFK
I have this like 11 minute monologue
thing that happens I learned that entire
script about a month before the movie
ever shot so I was like off-book as you
say I I did I didn't have to do it I
remember Oliver said okay well let's
let's let's do the courtroom sequence
and so I started it and I went all the
way through and it was a day and we had
extras like there and you know and and
they were there and he comes to me and
he says you can do the whole thing and I
said yeah I can do the whole thing he
says go back to your trailer give me 45
minutes I'm gonna set up six cameras or
four cameras or whatever and the sket
was seen was scheduled to be long's
three days we were supposed to be in
there three days we were done at noon
and so that I can't say that was one
take but we I did like because he had
his different cameras I did like four
takes and we were does yeah yeah when
you say let's have a catch is that your
terminology in Field of Dreams no it's
not mine in fact I had a hard time
saying that I used to say play catch
yeah because I I'm wondering I have a
catch as a kana I was told the director
the writer who doesn't I get so much
credit with Field of Dreams but it was
really Phil Robinson but he's not really
a sports guy and he wrote a movie that
none of you sports guys could possibly
write
he wrote a speech for James Earl Jones
at Mickey Mantle and and all the great
ones they can't articulate what it is
they love about the game not even you
yeah it took a kind of non-athlete and
the ray Kinsella character who writes
this it just writes a speech that we
just can't get out of our mind Vin
Scully like a chalkboard it's a race and
it's everything that good and could be
again and Jesus I just lost my place
where are we where were we
we're throat can you have a catch then
you have a catch and so I that didn't
come out of my mouth right yeah it just
sounds strange it's an e it's a New York
thing
okay and it's and for me it's like let's
play catch that can we play catch to
have a catch I struggled with that
believe it or not I heard 11-page
monologue and I go season two of
Yellowstone cables most watched new
series Kevin Costner where do you shoot
Yellowstone we should it in two places
Park City you know and then the
Bitterroot Valley which is really
significant to me because it's where
Lewis and Clark went through and you
know III never I can't stop thinking
about the history when I'm there because
they did that
something like 1803 and did anybody ever
do a Lewis and Clark movie they've been
a couple stabs at it one was started by
HBO and then for some reason they
stopped but it's not lost on me you know
when I'm making that that that series
when I look at at these mountains and
and the the truth of it is I'm haunted
by it by the history of it because I
mean when Lewis and Clark did go through
there they were helped and 70 years
later these settlers put up a fence and
they're these these people who Fredette
for thousands of years had been there
who would come through that valley to go
out to the plains hunt Buffalo and then
work their way back after the summer who
had helped these people 80 years later
they were gone and that's where I'm
working and so it's beautiful I look at
it on my days off I just you know I
feast on that kind of thing I'm not that
comfortable in the city you got a log
cabin
I got a cabin yeah it looked like a log
cabin yeah I got I got a little cabin
Ike I got a courage I got tractors I I
love that I'm I'm actually not a very
good craftsman it just I'll do it all
day can you fish yeah hunt yeah I have
bird dogs and you do the whole thing
yeah I do you go camo I listen I used to
get sent home and in sixth grade I used
to like kill these animals these rabbits
I would take these skins to school I
wanted to sell them because I remember
seeing in the movies how they Indians
tied them up you know and stretched them
out but can I said I'm gonna go since
all my pelts and I would get these notes
and go he cannot bring school you know
and I was like I was I was looking for
some kind of exchange you know because I
wanted commerce in my life and you go
you can't you can't do it I mean I was
in I was inducted to the Hall of the
cowboy Hall of Fame about a month and a
half ago there's a speech it's called
the American heritage Awards used to be
the cowboy Hall of Fame in Oklahoma and
what do I say because they wanted to
know about my interest in the West and I
I didn't I really didn't know hopefully
I hope you see the speech but I
basically started I never got past being
seven years old in the speech the whole
speech was about leading after that but
I remember in my in my kindergarten
class because they go well how do you go
to being this kind of lovingness because
I do westerns and and I said well I
remember kindergarten in Compton
California where I was lived and you
know kindergarten oh okay my brother was
five years older me sharing de-what
sharing day you bring your best stuff
sharing it that's what you bring and so
I did and I brought my dad's 3030 oh and
I walked to school
I brought my dad's 3030 to the
kindergarten class knew that I had the
best stuff like mine was way better than
anybody else not gun or right no that's
a rifle okay and I actually use it in
Yellowstone the same rifle my dad play
so you got her over your shoulder take
it to school I had it was way too heavy
for I'm like five years old so I bring
it and so what happens
they take the gun they put a note on my
chest cuz I don't know how to read yet
and then that note goes home with me and
I'm thinking I'm never walking home with
piece of paper on me again cuz it
completely sold me down the river my
periscope you said you took that gun out
of dad's closet it's like it was the
best stuff you should have seen the
other kids had nothing not compared to
what your greatest athletic achievement
is what my greatest one was a fly ball
that the love of the game I'd been
working in Yankee Stadium for about
eighteen days and I was really good to
the extras I was really good I throw
them balls I hit fungo up the butt
because we moved them we we'd moved them
all over the place and on the last day I
was a little bit hyped up because I had
to take some some pills to be pretty
juiced up I you know really did I was
like I'd been throwing 200 pitches a day
a you take a nymphet Amin's yeah
whatever it was I I said I not going to
get through this because the last day we
decided to - I'm not sure what it was
but the last day I just we shot six
hours we started that in the day and
that game ends at night and and we'd
already established where all the hits
for the game so I'm and we put the
cameras exactly where they went
in a normal televised game so we would
have that coverage and into the evening
the the fans of three or four thousand
fans were right behind the third-base
dugout a big fly ball goes up and I just
instinctly start running for it nobody
else moves because it's not gonna tie
into the thing and I already find myself
across the line and right there and I
you know I you know you know you know I
it's like you know you know I catch the
ball or something like that or whatever
so I walk back and I throw it again the
the the no no I know what happens the
fly went there I catch it I look at
everybody you know III tossed I just
hold the ball and I start to walk back
because I'm a little juiced up anyway I
just about in it and they're all the
Yankee fans at this point I'm just about
to walk back to the mound and somebody
said something derogatory toward me
and I stopped and the guy who gave me
the pills at one point said you know
you're gonna he says you know you're
gonna growl at somebody at some point
because it's real whatever and I didn't
and I it bugged me because eighteen days
of treating him good and I walked back
and now the 3,000 got really quiet and I
said you and I and and everybody looked
at me nobody said a word and then I
turned around to go back to the mound
and as soon as I started to go back to
the mound there's like New York turned
on me man these three thousand extras
they turned on me because and I and I
might now I'm walk the man I go why did
you do that Kevin after 18 days why did
you do that I get to the mound and guess
what this is my greatest feat another
fly ball goes up there but now it's a
major-league pop-up and I nobody moves
again and I realize I ran over there
again I think I'm juiced up and now I'm
in front of them and the ball is coming
down I'm thinking oh and they're going
yo sock Billy usin a really hate me you
sack Billy and I'm thinking about Jesus
I go catch up behind your back I go
ahead I can't catch it by my back
haven't caught it behind my back for
about 15 years catch it behind your back
now if I catch somebody they'll kill me
that thing you do in about three seconds
I finally go tough
my foot might I put the glove behind my
back and the ball went in and they're
like really quiet and I'm looking at
them and all 3000 turned to the one guy
who said that derogatory think yeah
Billy Chapel and I realized I I could
have they could have just killed me
humiliate if I'd but I had this internal
dialogue that had to happen in a second
but it felt like a lifetime so I walked
out back to the mound and they were back
on my side all right the Danites have I
said that they could have one question
who wants to be the spokesperson there
did your parents say you guys aren't
gonna be nothing what are you gonna do
and you got I could just I look at you
guys in it just it feels like sixth
grade and it's so perfect and you got
this job and you come here I love it
you pay to talk sports and hang out and
it's a good yes no I probably have the
worst question if you want me to go
first okay
I'm gonna give you guys two questions no
I let's go what's okay
okay kill McLovin in the movie draft day
you played sunny draft yes you drafted a
running back at number six overall do
you really think you could win with a
running back in today's NFL you went
full sake one with the Browns
God you mean you really watched way too
close and and look you know look my big
contribution there was you pancake
eating mother and I through that line in
because I had that was it was a
throwback to hearing the guy meeting
pancakes and I thought I have to I have
to echo that towards the end I listen
you know there's a we got as much
luggage logic as we could just not
enough for you yeah you're stickler I
did I would love to see you recreate
your character for like a Funny or Die
with Odell Beckham and Baker Mayfield
and make it seem like you're you're the
GM of the Browns right and then you do
something with them almost like a hype
video for the Browns season Larry
have a Dale Beckham and you have Baker
Mayfield I think that would be great
listen I I have you got enough things I
had I have I had a glass you know just
out there and playing and throwing the
ball around and just it was it was it
was it was a great movie it was a nice
extension of being able to do sports and
a great co-star to Paulie
I watched Field of Dreams just again the
other day everyone loves that movie it's
got a lot of legs that's gonna be around
forever but I was wondering when you're
getting pitched Field of Dreams when
they're pitching you you were at your
peak of stardom do you ever think this
could be really slowly got peak do you
ever think when you got pitch the idea
for Field of Dreams this could be really
silly it turned out fantastic I can tell
you exactly where I was when I read that
movie dan and I were talking about it
before we started to roll and I
apologized for humiliating you I
apologize to the audience to the you can
use that word if you just use it
sparingly and it's just like a sword
anyway
it's I try to put the audience on my
shoulder when I read something for the
first time because I got to make up my
mind I'm gonna leave my family to make a
movie I'm just gonna be out there like
there's a lot of things that go through
me and then it's like how are people in
the dark in a field if we pull this
movie off and I read that movie on the
couch and when I was done I thought this
movie has a little gold dust on it but
it is gonna be such a dangerous movie to
make and go oh how could this gentle
movie be a dangerous movie to make it's
exactly to your point which is
you'd make you look like a genius but
but the reality is that movie the edge
that it had to ride because it had no
car trash it had no fight it had no
thing it borderline goofy it was just
could be goofy you know all the way
through I mean there was a couple scenes
that they cut out I think they're
actually good scenes but one where's he
he goes in to check his hearing and he's
not crazy the doctors crazy so it's like
you know it's a very funny stuff Phill
Robinson who doesn't get enough credit I
think it could have been goofy and and
and and and and so it you're right that
was as a dangerous a movie as I made in
a way because it could have been
dismissed it's fluff in fact it was it
was you know somebody described it in a
big article about me one time during my
peak during my peak Wow that that you
know you know they were liking what I
was doing and then feel the dreams this
movies probably gonna get dismissed
I mean hadn't come out yet because
what's he doing over there you know
doing two baseball movies in a row but
honestly I I thought it had I just I
thought it had something special but I
knew how dangerous it was in a sense it
it could just it just borderline just be
so damn silly and I really tried to
watch that as I was on the set every day
the show is Yellowstone season apologies
new series debuts on paramount Network
that'll be June 19th at 10:00 Eastern
and Pacific great seeing you as always
thanks for thank you thanks Jerry time
Thank You Man Kevin Costner who peaked
during Field of Dreams we're a backup
system Patrick show for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]